non
motion unanime après le décès de la
comédienne alice sapritch le metteur en
scène jérôme savary témoigne en direct
dans ce journal
situation toujours bloquée en lituanie
les démonstrations de force de l'armée
soviétique reste sans effet sur les
autorités le salon du livre en direct
dans le 19/20 parmi nos invités
l'écrivain marocain tahar benjelloun
bonsoir tour à tour drôles ou tragiques
excentrique en ville et ne refusant
aucune difficulté à la scène un talent
un visage une personnalité hors du
commun
alice sapritch est morte ce matin
victime d'un malaise cardiaque à l'âge
de 73 ans portrait d'un monstre sacré
brossé par dominique poncet alice
sapritch dans son dernier rôle catherine
de médicis qu'elle avait créée pour le
petit écran
un média qu'elle affectionnait
particulièrement piste qui lui avait
permis avait-elle écrit dans ses
mémoires de devenir une femme publique
elle avait durement lutté pour devenir
star mais elle s'était toujours battu
avec des armes noble son esprit qu'elle
avait à serrer sa culture qui était
intimement son obstination qui était
sans faille et son talent qui lui
permettait d'aborder tous les registres
né en juillet 1916 à istanbul elle avait
débarqué à paris sans un sou vaillant
avec une seule idée en tête devenir
comédienne et elle était entrée au
conservatoire où elle disait n'avoir eu
qu'un maître louis jouvet saboter matt
d'oriental qui n'était pas alors au goût
du jour l'avait longtemps cantonné dans
des petits rôles de composition
c'est la maturité qui lui apporta le
succès la télévision lui offrir enfin
des rôles à la hauteur de son talent la
cousine bette la folcoche de vipère au
poing et aussi marie besnard qui lui
vaudra sont sept d'or le cinéma la gata
aussi lui offrant notamment devenir en
1971 l'irrésistible jane dans la folie
des grandeurs mais c'est jérôme savary
qui lui donna son rôle le plus
surprenant celui d'une ébouriffante
héroïne de bande dessinée dans super
dupont devenu star à la scène comme à la
ville
elle s'était composer un look de star
turban doré l'on fume cigarette
mais ces accessoires lui servait de
masquer un masque qui dissimulait une
femme généreuse et fidèle envers ses
vrais amis une femme lucide sur les faux
semblants de son métier
une femme dont le cran et est
exceptionnel malade depuis longtemps
personne ne l'entendît jamais égalé la
moindre plainte
alice sapritch droite
digne jusqu'au bout alors jérôme savary
vous avez souvent travaillé à dominique
penser le rappeler comme metteur en
scène avec alice sapritch quelle quelle
image quel souvenir gardez-vous de la
femme allait de la crise c'était une
femme tendre extrêmement fidèles comme
le a dit denis on sait tout à l'heure et
très belle je trouve qu'il y avait eu
une certaine injustice avec alyssa elle
s'en amuser et gagner sa vie avec ça
aussi bien pour pas oublier que elle
elle aimait c'était une vraie
professionnelle mais la justice a été de
considérer alice sapritch comme le porte
étendard de la laideur de la vulgarité
on se permettait avec cette femme les
plaisanteries les plus sordides et
plaisanteries qu'on n'aurait même pas
osé faire à son chien et elle gardait
toujours ce port de tête de princesse
égyptienne
cet humour froid elle foudroyé les gens
d'ailleurs qui se moquer d'elle un peu
comme cette femme qui joue dans les marx
brothers cette grande femme qui reste
toujours impassible très british avec
ses les marx brothers qui font les
gugusses tri et bien on a fait des
gugusses riz autour d'alice sapritch
c'était une une femme belle et fidèle
dans super dupont en effet ma banane
d'après godelieve j'en avais fait ma
marianne parce que je trouvais que
c'était une aile lui c'était une
réparation envers alice sapritch je
disais pourquoi at on pris brigitte
bardot puis catherine deneuve et
pourquoi ne prendrions nous pas
la troisième grande beauté de notre pays
qui est allé sapritch pour faire la
marianne des années 80 non c'était une
femme sensible et c'est pour ça que je
crois qu'elle est extrêmement populaire
vous m'avez dit tout à l'heure dans la
rue les gens les gens étaient émus
étaient touchés par la mort d'alice
sapritch c'était une femme qui était
très aimé car derrière tout les plus
strict on lui faisait faire
on sentait la tendresse et la
sensibilité
merci d'éviter alors vouliez brocardé
par les imitateurs notamment thierry le
luron qui est aussi son ami caricature
et parfois par quelques plumes féroce
alice sapritch savait toujours masqué
ses émotions et ses souffrances écouter
philippe bouvard l'animateur des grosses
têtes sur rtl qui invitait souvent la
comédienne c'est vrai que si elle a un
peu souffert de nos moqueries
elle a assumé finalement avec beaucoup
de courage et de lucidité parce que et
ses parents ça qu'on voit les grands
personnages et les grands acteurs
elle a su à un certain moment de sa
carrière transformer ou des défauts
caractériel ou de petites disgrâce
physique en en qualité professionnelle
et elle savait que elle existait pour
les gens à travers le personnage qu'elle
avait accepté de jouer et qui n'était
pas forcément le personnage privé quel
était le personnage pris les jambes
savary c'était un personnage aussi
extravagant que celui que l'on
présentait sur les différentes et c'est
moi moi j'aime pas pleurer sur la mort
de mes amis j'ai envie de presse que les
deux joyeux en parlant d' alice parce
que alice c'était la joie d'abord elle a
extrêmement bien vécu c'était une grande
amoureuse
vous savez quand on entrait chez elle
quand j'allais travailler chez alice
sapritch elles deux points cédant son
entrée et vous tourniez le regard sur la
gauche
hiré l'immense lead alice sapritch la
porte ouverte entouré de viol de parfum
c'était une grande gastronomes elle
mangeait voir manger des petits rouges
est sûre
un port de la méditerranée par alice
sapritch était un délice
donc j'ai pas envie d'être triste et je
suis sûr qu alice et je te le dis hein
on s'est beaucoup moqué le toit je pense
qu'en ce moment elle nous regarde et
elle va maintenant commencer
ok merci jérôme savary pour ce
témoignage ne manquez pas demain soir à
22h30 sur l'a3 la rediffusion de
l'émission d'henry chapier le divan
celui qui l'avait consacré donc à la
comédienne alice sapritch décédé ce
matin à l'âge de 73 ans l'actualité à
l'étranger c'est tout d'abord la
situation toujours bloquée en lituanie
l'armée soviétique a fait la
démonstration de sa force la nuit
dernière dans les rues de la capitale à
vilnius
mais sans pour autant infléchir la
détermination des autorités lituaniennes
commentaires d'hélène risacher
malgré les démonstrations de force
physique
le premier ministre de lituanie affirme
nous n'avons pas peur et les députés
lituaniens viennent d'élire une partie
de leur gouvernement
mais la nuit dernière vers 3 heures une
centaine de chats de véhicules de
transport de troupes ont traversé tout
le centre de vilnius ce convoi de
l'armée soviétique transportant plus
d'un millier de soldats armés s'est
dirigé vers des casernes dans la
banlieue de vilnius
vers midi aujourd'hui une quinzaine de
camions militaires apparemment vide sont
passés sous les fenêtres du parlement
lituanien émotion chez les députés dès
l'aube ils avaient voté une résolution
en cas d'actes de violence qui les
empêcheraient d'agir les députés
confient leur pouvoir aux représentants
de la lituanie à washington et au
vatican le président du parlement vie
totale quand vergiss disais tout à
l'heure nous avons senti que nous étions
vraiment dans un pays occupé la nuit
dernière
il faut qu michael gorbatchev sache que
nous nous sommes armés que de nos
profondes convictions dans la justesse
de notre cause
le bras de fer entre moscou et vilnius
continue les indépendantistes lituanien
s'attendent encore des heures de
tensions difficile ce week end
l'ultimatum de moscou a ordonné aux
soldats lituanien déserteurs de l'armée
rouge de regagner leur unité
le délai est maintenant passé et pour
l'instant moscou n'a pris aucune mesure
particulière contre eux mais la tension
s'accentue ce soir encore le ministère
des affaires étrangères soviétique
invite fermement les diplomates
étrangers se trouvant actuellement en
lituanie a quitté cette république balte
et les journalistes étrangers qui
doivent
temporairement s'abstenir de s'y rendre
donc déclaration ce soir du ministère
des affaires étrangères soviétique près
de 8 millions de hongrois semble prêt à
mettre un terme demain à 43 ans de
pouvoir communiste les premières
élections libres vont marquer un
changement politique considérable et
accentue aussi le virage économique
amorcée depuis deux ans la hongrie veut
et va s'ouvrir à l'europe de l'ouest
premier exemple aux environs de budapest
d'une société hongroise récemment
racheté par les dirigeant d'une pme
française
reportage marie-claire tiers et
jean-jacques le deuil jacques marionnet
producteurs d'aspergés in vitro en
sologne et contacté il ya trois ans par
les responsables hongrois du laboratoire
d'état mairie clown il leur recommande
500 mille plants d'aspères dont il ne
verra jamais la couleur
lien alors en hongrie et les frapper par
la taille des installations leur
capacité de production par la compétence
scientifique des ingénieurs mais
catastrophé par l'anarchie totale
un programme de recherche complètement
dispersés et aucune gestion
profitant de la loi du 1er janvier 90
qui l'y autorisent il rachète le tout
est bien sûr réorganiser à
l'administration sur son personnes en
avait 30
je suis pas si loin des cons bah oui
c'est trop lourd et il y en a besoin que
de deux mais il y en avait partout dans
les couloirs et tout le monde se
promenait maintenant ça ça va bien vous
donner un exemple c'est que quelques une
fois ils les ont cherché les centres on
voulait planter acclimater des
artichauts ou par exemple des aspects
ils disaient mais où les serres mais
dans les serres il y avait 500 milles
bananiers et alors tout le monde se
féliciter d'avoir réussi un travail
formidable
et puis mais les bananiers il avait
oublié je crois des bandes c'est tout
avec la privatisation les hongrois
découvre l'économie de marché et espère
que les élections conforteront
s'échangeant grand jour ce sera dimanche
et la plupart d'entre nous espère avoir
une chance de changer les choses en gris
on vote pour le changement et
nous avons le choix entre 52 candidats
et c'est beaucoup trop
je pense que ce seront les prochaines
élections qui seront vraiment
démocratique
vous voulez dire dans quatre ans oui
dans quatre ans les hongrois espère que
lors des élections de demain une
majorité va s'imposer sinon une
coalition de petits partis rendrait la
situation ingouvernable et
compromettrait la réorganisation
actuelle de l'économie
il l'est encore qui s'exprime en force
au salon du livre à paris avant de
rejoindre pour confirmation elisabeth
kelidjian cet ouvrage du dessinateur
roumain mia stanescu qui après quinze
ans de lutte contre le régime de
monsieur coc secoue publie donc un
nouveau recueil consacré à la fois la
roumanie mais aussi aux autres pays de
l'est qui s'émancipe
actuellement c'est publié aux éditions
bernard barrault elisabeth kelidjian les
pays de l'est très très bien représenté
au salon du livre cette année alors les
pays de l'est très bien représentée nous
avons malheureusement égaré notre
écrivain polonais un véhicule et vite il
ya une vingtaine de personnes qui le
cherchent outremont dans le salon du
livre je suis pas sûr qu'il arrive avant
la fin du 19/20 tous les simples
mondiale que s'il ya fonds écrivains des
pays d'est une centaine de
professionnels du livre des critiques
des éditeurs ne sont pas là simplement
pour des raisons symboliques mais
vraiment pour arriver à des accords de
coopération culturelle des accords de
coopération éditoriaux avec la france
donc dans quelques jours on devrait
pouvoir faire un bilan et montrer que
beaucoup d'initiatives ogouma ni hongrie
en tchécoslovaquie en pologne aussi au
permis aux éditeurs qui se trouve là bas
et qui travaillent dans des conditions
très difficile d'avancer d'avoir une
aide concrète de la froisse merci
elizabeth nous retournerons dans
quelques minutes au salon du lit
rejoindre notamment l'écrivain marocain
tahar ben jelloun mais nous devons
maintenant la page politique en france
avec l'arrivée d'une nouvelle formation
sur la scène politique française
jean charbonnel épaulé par deux autres
anciens ministres du général de gaulle à
fond dès aujourd'hui la convention pour
la 5ème république sa vocation
constituer un pôle gaulliste de la
majorité présidentielle en s'alliant à
la france unie de jean pierre soisson
reportage éric perreault serge florimont
c'est par un oui franc et massif que les
petites formations gaulliste de gauche
ont décidé aujourd'hui de rejoindre la
majorité présidentielle derrière jean
charbonnel car pour eux l'héritage du
général de gaulle est beaucoup mieux
préservés par françois mitterrand que
par jacques chirac
les socialistes affirme et ils ont
accepté les idées force du gaullisme
les institutions de la vème république
une défense nationale indépendante la
confédération européenne est aussi la
participation alors que le rpr ne
cesserai de s'abîmer dans une
irrésistible dérive droitière
je vois les gens qui réclament le retour
le retour tant locale que je vais la
dure la vie ou à l'écrit n'y a pas si
longtemps alors je suis aligné de tout
ça c'est tout à fait le contraire de ce
que l'on nous a dit et maintenant on
nous parle français refermée sur elle
même
monsieur pasqua ne l'a jamais de ne
jamais nier nous barre des valeurs
communes qu'il a avec le front national
alors la justice elle ne supporte pas
c'est la vie parce que je dis que c'est
à digne de l'héritage gaulliste jean
charbonnel a démissionné du groupe rpr
de l'assemblée nationale la semaine
dernière désormais son horizon et
ailleurs vers une confédération du
centre gauche aux côtés de l'association
des démocrates et des radicaux de gauche
et peut-être bientôt aussi dans le
gouvernement de michel rocard à
montpellier un millier de personnes ont
défilé aujourd'hui à l'appel du front
national qui entendait ainsi rendre un
dernier hommage à la petite cécile
enlevé le 7 mars est assassiné les
parents de la fillette âgée de 11 ans
avait dénoncé hier toute initiative je
cite tendant à utiliser le meurtre de
cécile à des fins racistes et xénophobes
alors qu'un marocain âgé de 31 ans
familier des parents mahmoud belle fille
aurait avoué devant la justice de son
pays avoir enlevé et assassiné l'enfant
l'homme sera jugé prochainement au maroc
150 associations réunies aujourd'hui à
lyon pour participer aux états généraux
de la communauté musulmane en france
islam économie éducation mais aussi
racisme et environnement social ont été
au coeur des débats
reportage à lyon jacques baudou dès
l'ouverture des états généraux de la
communauté des musulmans de france les
600 délégués des associations réunies à
lyon marqué une réelle volonté de s'unir
car ils veulent être des français à part
entière depuis 30 ans discours que vous
avez entendu ce matin était un discours
révélateur d'une volonté on volonté
farouche de la cause d'une communauté
qui veut véritablement arrivé vers
l'union
mais le véritable problème est que ces
français de confession islamique
s'éparpillant de multiples associations
et cet après midi toujours à lyon la
confédération nationale des rapatriés
français contesté la représentativité
des états généraux et pourtant il ya une
certaine identité 2 nous voulons l'unité
nous voulait là nous la voulons l'unité
ya pas de problème pour nous tous les
harkis et tous les français musulmans
sont des frères et nous mais
effectivement nous pensons tous la même
chose seulement il ya des gens qui ont
des arrières pensées et ces gens là il
faut que la base sache exactement qu'est
ce qui les attire
soit le vedettariat soit d'aider des
questions pécuniaires
les français musulmans réussiront ils
leur pari fait se rassembler mais que
d'obstacles à franchir
nous allons retourner dans un instant au
salon du livre au grand palais à paris
pour parler notamment littérature avec
l'écrivain marocain tahar ben jelloun il
publie son dernier roman jours de
silence à tanger aux éditions du seuil
monsieur ben jelloun bonsoir vous
m'entendez oui je vous entends quel rôle
vous écrivain êtes vous prêt à jouer
pour favoriser l'apaisement des
intolérances good life
il faut il faut travailler beaucoup il
faut il faut écrire beaucoup et puis il
faut surtout essayer de dialoguer avec
les gens parfois il très difficile de
parler avec les fanatiques la fois où je
me suis vraiment trouvé devant un mur
c'est lorsque j'étais en face de
fanatiques de fanatiques par par des
finissants quelqu'un qui n'écoute pas et
qui ne répond pas il a hélas son
discours embêtant il donne alors il faut
être plus patient et plus intelligent
que lui et continuer à faire deux à
écrire et à faire des livres c'est un
travail de longue haleine il faut
travailler beaucoup pas seul nous
mesurons dans ce salon
l'engouement pour les pays de l'est
c'est un engouement qui se traduit sur
tous les terrains y compris le terrain
économique
vous n'avez pas peur que cela se passe
petit peu au détriment des écrivains
notamment du sud non je pense que c'est
très bien que s'intéresse aussi aux
écrivains des pays de l'est parce que ce
n'est que justice
et je pense que ce qui va être
victorieux dans tout ça sa littérature
si notre littérature est bonne elle
résistera si elle est mauvaise
disparaîtra et c'est pas les écrivains
de l'est qui vont nous faire de l'ombre
ou quelque chose comme ça je trouve que
c'est plus on parle de notre littérature
mieux ça vous et encore une fois je
pense que ce sont les littératures les
plus intéressantes qui vont rester c'est
pas vrai les modes qui vont les imposer
alors elisabeth kelidjian est à vos
côtés pour parler aussi de votre dernier
roman jours de silence à tanger oui oui
alors jour des silos cette hausse est
la journée d'un homme d'un vieil homme
malade solitaire là c'est finalement les
vocations trêve ils ont cogité très dieu
de tout ce que vous perdez tout ce qui
vous échappe
contre l'avis staline est ce qui vous
reste coi des souligné bien si fier
comme vous dites c'est ce qui reste mais
mu est importante
c'est un hommage à rendre à au temps qui
passe qui laisse des traces et qui
parfois peut être méchant donc la
littérature est parfois une façon de
colmater les brèches et de rendre
hommage à ceux qui vieillissent bien et
il y en a qui vieillissent mal enfin bon
personnage ne vieillit pas très bien
mais en même temps il a une telle
énergie une telle envie de vivre que je
lui rends hommage par cette espèce de
colère qu'il a cette révolte qu'il a et
c'est une façon aussi de de dire que
dans les pays du sud commandant maroc
être vieux n'est pas indigne merci
monsieur benjelloun d'avoir été l invité
du 19/20 ce soir en direct du salon du
livre au grand palais les sports
maintenant pour souligner tout d'abord
le fiasco des athlètes français cet
après midi aux championnats du monde de
cross-country à aix les bains
les surprises sont venues du maroc nous
en parlions et des états unis
commentaire d'alain leblanc pour ce 18e
mondial de cross ont croisé les doigts
pour la tenante du titre la française
annette sergent mais on savait aussi la
lyonnaise en perte de confiance elle ne
termine que 17e à 34 secondes de la
première à savoir l'américaine lynch et
ning ce qui s'est imposé de bout en bout
sur le tracé de 6 km qu'elle boucle dans
le temps de 19 minutes vingt-et-une la
portugaise dias coiffe de peu pour
l'argent la soviétique
romanova chez les hommes la france
comptait beaucoup sur thierry pantel le
numéro 159 qui décroche pourtant peu
après le 3e kilomètre
c'est alors que surgit john ngugi le
quadrupède champion du monde
numéro 2 196 toujours spectaculaire le
kényan au passage des buts qu'il avale
d'un seul bond puis surgit juste avant
le quart d'heure de course l'éthiopien à
nice
abb mais même ce dernier ne résiste pas
au final du marocain khalid skah qui
créé l'énorme surprise le petit homme
vert déclare en passant l'arrivée des 12
km 2 134 21 qu'il veut battre le record
du monde du 10000 m le savoyard polar
pain se classe 21e et premier français
un résultat d'entente très décevant pour
les athlètes français pourtant très
attendu à aix-les-bains sa vie des
images de formule 1 où le brésilien
ayrton senna apparaît déjà maître chez
lui il a signé le meilleur temps des
premiers essais du grand prix du brésil
bien sûr commentaires de didier balès le
deuxième grand prix de la saison un
terreau la gousse 4 km 32 bénéficie d'un
revêtement de piste contestées c'est
neil burger confirme la pleine forme de
l'écurie championne du monde le
brésilien réalise sa 43e pole position
en 17 27 devant l'autrichien une 17 88
et williams renault de buddh scène et
patrese partiront en deuxième ligne
améliorant la fiabilité du v10 au fil
des courses
déception chez ferrari après des
problèmes d'embrayage mansell réalise le
cinquième temps alain prost le sixième
en une 18,63 la firme italienne semble
rencontrer des difficultés pour réaliser
l'amalgamme parfait entre pilotes
châssis et moteur côté français alesi
s'élancera en quatrième ligne
aliot en cinquième et puis en natation
le prêt d'un frédéric loafers à
améliorer cet après-midi le record de
france du 200 m 4 nages voilà l'édition
à peu près complète dans un instant elle
le sera dans deux minutes exactement
avec la météo de florence klein
n'oubliez pas elle va vous le rappelez
de changer l'heure de votre monde
avancer la dune heure la nuit prochaine
je vous retrouve à 22h15 pour soir 3
très bon début de soirée
une